example one okay but she I'm going to
use this notation over here so you've
got this elongated s which means the
thing you're about to see I want you to
anti-differentiate it and the the
function I'm going to give you is this
now I'm giving you this one on purpose
because we've just looked at it right I
want to undo the process of
differentiation that we did before
okay now you took a function you took
the index you brought it down the front
you multiplied by that and then you
reduce the index by one remember that
okay so to undo that we need to do
everything I just described but in
Reverse so we're going to take this
index and we're going to we're not gonna
flip it I hope not
we're gonna add one to it right so let's
do that okay I'm gonna come to trying to
form a rule around it in a second okay
I've increased the index okay that six
is still hanging around there and then
after I increase it I have to undo the
other thing which means I have to divide
right I have to divide by that index
does that make sense okay let me say
this again okay when you are
differentiating you reduce the index by
one you and then you only said it again
you multiply it by the index and then
you reduce the index by one remember
that okay so I've done both of those
things in Reverse I've increased the
indexed and then instead of multiplying
I divided by that
say again would that be too acute well
I'm not finished with this line but it
will be in a second Laurie did you have
a question I am gonna come down to the
next line and simplify this in a second
but I wanted you to know where I got
those numbers from okay John say yeah
hold on a second year 12 so I have to
ask you to say the third time John but
this time I can hear you can you repeat
your question please yeah absolutely
this is why I didn't go straight to the
next thing
okay when we did this in the first place
if I gave you say I'm gonna give you a
different example now when I take
something like this if I ask you to
differentiate it then two things happen
right first I'm going to market multiply
by this index let's do that here comes
we've multiplied first
in fact it's so important I'm gonna
write it down that's the first thing I
did and then secondly you can all tell
me write you yeah you reduce the index
by one right like so said okay so reduce
index now that order matters doesn't it
right you can't reduce the index and
then multiply you get a different result
wouldn't you right so this is step one
this is step two now what I'm trying to
do is undo exactly that I'm trying to
undo exactly that so let's come over to
this example now right instead of I'm
gonna go in Reverse instead of reducing
the index I'm going to increase the
index right so that's why I went from
two to three are you happy with that
step okay so I've undone this and now I
need to undo this how do you undo
multiplication you divide which is why I
divided down here and the order of
course just like before matters because
you get a different art are completely
if you did them the other way are you
happy with that have a look at this guy
can we do it to this as well
[Applause]
this is a bit sneaky right because you
like increase the index what index is it
well there is an index it's hiding there
the index here how could we write this
with an index it's one lot of X to what
power zero right there are no X's which
is why it's exit powers here does that
make sense okay now we can go through
this I'm gonna increase the index which
gives me increase from zero it goes to
one so I can write our and X and then
what do I do now this is X to power of
one I should say I've got to undo this
as well right which in this case has no
effect when you divide by one but you
had to do it anyway question why are you
talking about this - here are you
talking about sorry which which part you
talking about are you talking about this
part here ah good question so you asked
him out what comes next is that what
you're asking right that's a really
great question
okay now let's let's just simplify this
and then I'll answer that question some
of you wanted to do this right away
what is 6x cubed divided by 3 - X cubed
and then this guy just becomes takeaway
X now hold on a second and this comes to
will annoys question right this is not
the function that you started with this
is not the function you started with
this isn't the primitive that you did in
part a there was a what was there he was
like a plus 1 right now here's the issue
right these two functions here this guy
and this guy the gradients on every part
of those curves are identical the
gradients are identical what's different
with this or with this or with this is
its position right its position so this
is already our biggest fundamental
difference between like when you go back
to this process when you get a primitive
right there isn't just a primitive there
a single one there's actually a whole
family of them right now the way we
catch this the way we say well it could
be anything any constant number could
tag along the end here is we say well
there could be any constant instead of
writing constant cuz we're lazy we
choose a letter which is the letter C
okay so this is actually something which
you have to include all the way through
because any of these could differentiate
to give you 6x squared minus 1 does that
make sense okay so this is important
this guy here is a whole family of
primitives and that's so important I'm
gonna write it down okay so um can we
can we codify this a little bit we're
gonna focus are you a question yeah come
up you're talking about this one here
so excellent power 0 is just 1 so that's
why we can sort of get away with not
writing it right but I need to see that
it's X to the power of 0 in order to
work out how to undo this process of
differentiation right so if you go back
to when we did question a earlier on
right there was a minus X here and it
ended up with minus 1 so in order to get
back from the minus 1 to this minus X I
need to write it in index form so I can
see I'm increasing an index and then I'm
dividing by that that make sense ok last
little thing before I set you loose on
this exercise right Shh what we want to
do is generalize this is there a way I
can do this a little more automatically
if for example I asked you to
anti-differentiate any power of X X
cubed x to the power of 100 you can slap
a number at the front a coefficient if
you like right with respect to X what
were the two things that we did to undo
this process of differentiation
step one we increase the index by one so
the index is currently N what would it
be if I increased it by 1 and plus 1 and
then the second thing I did was I
divided by this new power which is
n plus one like so okay there was long
one last thing I needed to do because
this is not the only thing that would
differentiate to that I have to include
this plus C and it's actually got a name
all by itself this little guy here it's
actually called and I've been avoiding
saying it until this last moment because
I'm I finally kind of would say it right
it's the constant of this process
anti-differentiation it has another name
which is integrating now I've been
avoiding saying this word because it
sort of comes out of left field why
would the opposite of differentiating be
called integrating what does that even
mean
we're gonna save that for a future
lesson but it's the reason the reason
I'm telling you now is because this plus
C it's name is the constant of
integration it's what you get when you
go through this process of
anti-differentiation this process of
integration it appears here to cover the
whole family okay any questions